this evening we brought Tennessee right
up to Broadway let's all join in the fun
come on let's go with my head down in my
eyes and she says and I stand look to
the breakfast table while the kids are
going off to school goodbye and she
reaches out and takes my hand and
squeezes it and says are you feeling hon
[Music]
and I look across it smiling lips that
warm I don't see my modern son and if
that's not loving me then all I've got
to say God didn't make many green apples
nits don't rain
never since amateur
and when myself is feeling low I think
about her face and mine
[Music]
go to supervisor Chad look top income
type maintenance you can do it in the
look at the lookup tables
missing the birthday party we didn't get
invited corn on account wife's on
Saturday night not once wait
[Music]
I sleep
[Music]
we'll see to the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
country music is hot right now I think
funny for everyone to say but I'm just
trying to play as much music as possible
really
working working with royalties and
licensing for
for years and she's ready to phase that
out
sure was about it bad decision getting
on this [ __ ] road damn it
hey Herman
[Music]
they used to call me the Brazilian
hillbilly and then someone they said
that's too long man we gotta start
calling him brazil billy time went by
really quick for me seeing you on Friday
and Saturday nights will not be working
the front door at Roberts Western world
you know I'm always been glad to be a
part of the family
hey folks doing welcome to Roberts
Western world it wasn't until I came to
Nashville and it was like wow this is
pretty amazing
I was I was coming around to learn this
lifestyle it's this thing that yes so
unusual but to me I love the music and I
want to sing the music I want to play
that music a lot of great memories from
those days but it's just one of those
things everybody thinks it is what it is
man I got to be part of what it is I am
saying it is what it was schmuck ya know
it is what it was
a really good friend of mine chorion
says last year he was able to get me a
meet Greek with Mel Tillis on his bus
and of course a I went there dressed to
the nines and totally 1950s western wear
and as I walked onto the bus they're
about to introduce me to Mel Tillis and
before they even said my name he stood
up and pointed muse like that man right
there I was had a tie a [ __ ] tie
I grew up being around country-western
music a lot for my parents at our house
we had a jukebox in 1954 waltzer that
played 45 would always got me close to
country music was something that no
matter the way I felt being happy sad or
just content there was some type of song
out there that I could relate to and it
seems like everything that's out now is
you got a sing about this you got a sing
about the party's down at the beach and
there's no there's just no soul to to
the country music anymore we were
honestly just looking for a place that
offered this music every single night
yeah the legions just it was just the
perfect spot we were all just hanging
out as pals and I got offered to move
forward on having a music night and it
was just a perfect partnership because
it's really keeping this place afloat
it's just it's kind of unbelievable
something that we were doing just
because we love the music and we love
dancing to being a thriving spot for a
rebirth of country music
[Applause]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
then can you do me a big favor then can
you just go to the front to the ticket
stand hey Mike can you go to the ticket
stand and and asked for the buddy like a
little one of the tip jars and put it
right there in front I could do it but -
just so just just write a note saying
like it this is a free event you know
you house like a suggested donation kind
of thing yeah then what what do you need
up front I'm just trying to configure
the stage [ __ ] I'm trying to get
everybody on stage so we can do a
soundcheck okay seems like nobody want
to get that going first
nobody's going first let's just let's
just do that you work on that let's just
we we need to configure some [ __ ] on
stage right yeah actually
come with me right now okay if you got a
second yeah so what we need to do we're
gonna get a tip jug out front
[Music]
one thing is dude like it's just you
kind of just wing it a lot we just kind
of wing it a lot just go by like who's
Brandon he'll just fall out whatever we
usually do I no rhyme or reason do we
have a I just have it on here
this is the honky Tonk iPad
[ __ ] work this thing
[ __ ] it's just write this on Oh sheet of
paper
[Music]
that a music stand anywhere around
[Music]
sorry I'm excited to hear you play oh
yeah
there's a good there's a good dance
crowd alright Joe thanks excited hear
you alright
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I said well that's what Terry
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the song look at your pictures
too often my favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
but they say
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you great thank you thank you
w - really appreciate that was great
thank you seven great gets burnt because
burnt didn't leave anything left out
there
[Music]
all right good evening everybody how are
you my next big round of applause once
again for our sponsor this evening
rabbit's western world
my name is Beck paintball it's real
honor and a pleasure being here with you
tonight and it's a real honor and a
pleasure to introduce to you you're
listening and dancing pleasure
the fabulous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for singing man oh yeah yeah man
I'm I'm I'm tickled it you guys want to
come play hard and stuff man you guys
are a band really great
I love you oh man ransom we're I'm gonna
find somewhere to get you in this bath
yep anytime
[Music]
[Music]
you know walk this sucker I yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course
[Music]
whoa the nightlight ain't no good life
but it's my life many of this always
constantly amazed by the job people's
eyes varying degree of importance they
put on time-sensitive
it's like showing up on time we gotta be
at the radio station in the studio if
you're gonna park and walk at least in
football Felix at the studio from Norman
Park
with whatever people we've got to come
into the studio
in 15 minutes and the place is 15
minutes from the far
[Music]
somehow
live from Music City USA this is the
all-nighter
I'm Marcia Campbell on 650 a.m. and
worldwide at WSU online.com the station
that made country music famous
[Music]
so is this your first tree oh yes as a
trio yes these guys are all professional
this is all day individual yeah what you
just started right at the top it's great
you're here ws am i I know you respect
those call letters yeah Marcia can we
step inside right here and you have a
second you have the second part of the
first
[Music]
I was leaving always on my mind home
never home anytime every front door on
me over yeah I'm fine that door open
they're just tired be mean exit for the
running
within me there
surrounding me
as real as any
well as follows stone I don't run is hot
the insu Robins been my nature and upon
me
it's me
[Music]
always every front door and me open I
would find my back door open there just
had to be makes it for the running kind
yeah they're just happy excellent
[Music]
well here in the WSM studios we have a
unique blend of honky-tonk Baker's built
in the Nashville sound representing
classic country music from Ray Price the
Louvin Brothers Webb Pierce Buck Owens
monkey love Don Gibson and if you're
into Mel Tillis the list goes on and on
and on and on as well Kevin again we've
got a history some bluegrass music and
we do have a history attempt at the
world's largest square dances in July
Uncle Dave Macon days we did it for a
minute didn't we we almost had it
yeah and impress right yes I Kevin with
the hog slop string yes you're
performing with them and you are no
stranger to fiddle contests and some
bluegrass background and a champion
musician around this region as well when
no one else showed up to the contest
yeah you all are performing in just a
few hours a short nap day tonight you'll
be on stage doors open at 8 p.m.
Tommy Ash at 9 p.m. and 10 o'clock
you'll be taking the stage 3 country
tenors again that's tonight Tuesday
night American Legion Post 82 Nathan
Belt
Kevin Martin and Logan Leger make up the
three country tenors
[Music]
I love you so much I can't leave you
even though my mind tells me I should
but then you come home and tell me that
you love me all my thoughts of leaving
do no good
you've got me heart over mine wear it
all the time knowing you will always be
the same you keep hurting me I know but
I just can't let you go
plus my heart won't let my
[Music]
yes indeed - 650 a.m. WSM the three
country tenors so tell me a little bit
about brendan Malone we could say all
kinds of things about him but he's
actually in the room my name is Brendan
Malone I'm 30 years old my social
security number is I'm really looking
forward to coming and visiting and and
doing some honky-tonkin with you guys
tonight this is something that's been
going on for a while yeah well if you do
enjoy country western music you can find
it down at American Legion Post 82 we we
hold music mostly from anywhere from the
1940s to about 1966 before that's where
we try to keep it at it's nice to have a
little place to step back in time well
you all are young okay so the folks on
the radio did I love that fact because
it's like not everyone your age as you
know is into what we love so I
appreciate your love and respect for our
music and you thank you thank you and
WSM for providing a platform for us to
come and broadcast this yeah can we pass
it back yeah yeah yeah we okay good I
know but this is just so we get more
people there no excuses for not to be
filming that's a free event that's right
I'll mention that free admission tonight
oh yeah
WSM listeners they love free
[Music]
[Applause]
it
hi Terry this is Brendon Malone call on
behalf of the American Legion Post 82 in
Inglewood can you please just give me a
call whenever you are available thank
you all right yes hi Lauren my name is
Brendon Malone and I'm calling on behalf
of the American Legion Post 82 what I'm
looking into is full I'm sorry go ahead
yes hi Valerie I'm not too entirely sure
on who I need to speak with just
actually the let's see here yes hi
Whitney
um is there a manager available to speak
with yes hi um my name is Brendon Malone
and may have your name hey ray um I'm
calling on behalf of the American Legion
Post 82 here in East Nashville we have
the a biggie event each each week and
it's a called honky-tonk Tuesday's it's
a PAC dance for it's a great thing to
see and it's also just kind of like a
time machine you walk in there and it's
exactly straight from the 50s exactly
exactly and um and I was just wondering
if this is something that your
dealership downtown would be interested
in partnering up with other local
companies to to sponsor these nights yes
sir
I appreciate that thank you any um would
you be able to spell his last name for
me sir thank you sir
then they I really appreciate that ray
thank you you too ray take care bye-bye
so Pete do you remember the first time
that we started coming to lead yeah yeah
it was good yeah up up took up on me
that week and when I do we got going
yeah we uh we put together the the pizza
boys yeah your own little security team
you got took care of those guys anyway
yeah you you were the one who you know
we're pretty persistent about us getting
in there to do music yeah and you know I
I gotta say thank you for that when I
was in charge we should head on down to
the Legion check it out I'm ready to go
when y'all huh my cowboy boots jump oh
yeah you sure do when you started I
weighed like you said Tuesday night was
slow and I did I don't know we might
have had 50 people a night I'd say was
it doing now four hundred five hundred
papers and the summer got all the way up
to five hundred people who couldn't even
find you start leaving cuz of no parking
yeah I've seen them standing there two
or three deep at the bar waiting for
drinks
y'all done great and you've done great
man you know you made something big
money for them thank you all that would
have never happened if it wasn't for you
on the Tuesday night did you
did you notice like a big change with
the Legion yeah
nice for people they they they don't
look nice but they're nicer people you
know they come just anyway don't matter
you could look anyway in your yeah well
yeah
Hey
[Music]
y'all do
and
they say that loves or
[Music]
but cane
[Music]
and yeah
[Music]
and
[Music]
we're not
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how's everybody doing on the Tuesday
night American Legion Posts 82 everybody
sorry for Tuesday want to thank
everybody for coming out on another
installment of our Hokey Talk Tuesday
series here PO se D to my fans the
cowpoke's folks yeah yeah we just vamp
on the one with the stop yeah see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a big big country dancing out
there we love planet from post 82
honky-tonk Tuesday's so happy you both
could be here you've got a big little
Tim job down here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I find it fascinating that something
that I tried so hard to keep alive in
this town is now alive and doing well
because of people like you
and of course American engine boasting
me too it's amazing really
it's just amazing it's something that
you know lays on me pretty heavy after
you know my story on the fiber told you
but I lost my stepmother in Baghdad in
2007 and he was in the Marine Corps yeah
so it's like that's always been like a
really really cool thing to share with
the Legion and on top of like music it's
like you know the old George Jones -
who's gonna feed their shoes yeah who's
gonna walk that walk you know who's
gonna play at the Opera at the Wabash
Cannonball yeah
who's gonna play their hearts and so to
get to be a new
[Music]
you know who's gonna feel their shoes
yes
[Music]
operators to count folks we got one more
for you want to thank American Legion
Post 82 everybody and most of all hey
and most of all we want to thank each
and every
[Music]
time
[Music]
Oh My yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the American legions I gotta stay in
existence help people get involved
because the over people us yeah we can't
do a lot of things I mean this is just
because it's been a family it's amazing
we mean my way of talking about it all
the time
on Tuesday night it's just such a damn
asphere is amazing
I'm surprised we've not had any
situation somebody we've had to throw
somebody yeah yeah it's never happened
though
I mean maybe somebody waving its rally
we have no but seriously you guys have
been so sweet to us I there there are
there aren't words and I know it's it I
know it's a mutual relationship with
everything of it but gosh we love y'all
y'all got a good sound now yeah yeah I
like everybody to get something gangster
yeah thanks
what amazes me is that the younger
people that are coming in to the
American Legion and supporting us and
loving the Old South country music you
guys are playing and bringing that back
and that's what's making it Nick there's
the old Tex Ritter or so he says there
there are Cowboys to ride the range that
ride them far near Minnie there are
Cowboys who ride the range so rather
than fight for a near Minnie play the
old guitar but never rope the steer and
I think that may be the surprise what we
do
does some degree I need to close my tab
there goes there goes pickled as the
best beer can in the world right there
dang look at that thing select stock
just like Guinness select stockings
whatever you do the cores in the
narragansett for Saudi highway robbery
wearing it together yeah Monday nights
and but well we ought to put together
and together and put together a new sort
of setlist yeah even this [ __ ] that is
just like totally off my radar like ten
little bottles or the Johnny bonds are
no rye whiskey with him doing a extra
more drunkard version the tech forever
impossible right right anything else
cool going on this week it's
I said I said something was like how
does that work and somebody said oh I've
gotta I've gotta go home like rush home
after this and there's something I was
like well Lisa's Friday and as soon as I
said it I was like oh so Friday I'm
gonna pack up pack her up back man
shoe daddy l not bad well it's nice
meeting you yeah my name's Dave
d'Artagnan hey what do you say old boy
[Music]
tonight and Tokyo is full of blood
vision people everywhere but visit
people just know I wanna go straight
[Music]
I wanna go steaks
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
said a while
look around get up and leave
I wanna go steaks
[Music]
I wanna go space
[Music]